I just I'm really just enjoying my life
and my time with my baby and family and
Chloe's making sure her daughter true
Thompson lives her best life too I'm
gonna figure it all out
the reality star documented her
one-year-old daughter's fairy tale day
with cousin dream Kardashian all over
Instagram this weekend the girls started
off playing with sidewalk chalk two year
old dream giving off serious princess
vibes in a blue tutu dress
and silver headbands while true sported
a red and white tie-dye look later the
cousins had a magical bash complete with
grownup fairies and to their very own
fairy wings dream rocked the same
whimsical blue dress but swapped her
headband for a matching hair tie
meanwhile true opted for a wardrobe
change slipping into a similar pink look
which she completed with a unicorn
headband and flower crowns it was this
isn't the first time the little top
chloe shares with extra stin thompson
has had her dreamy playdate
documented on social media the cousins
also got together back in August but
this time it was dreams dad Rob
Kardashian posting all the pics check
out this sweet photo of dream and true
hanging by the pool in their adorable
one-piece swimsuits Rob also shared this
photo of his daughter with ex blac Chyna
lounging in a chair and the caption my
little lady acts like she's 50 years old
Chloe later posted this snap of the
cousins munching on snacks in their high
chairs wishing followers a happy Sunday
I feel great
[Music]